In this homework assignment, we asked you to
write a function called auto debug, which takes a
test piece of code, a test list and a test interesting,
which checks if the code is interesting in some way.
What we really mean is if there is some kind
of bug that we know is going to happen. So we
have this test specifically to check for it. In this
case, the test is interesting if it contains A plus B
on the same line, and variable A and variable B
before that line. So how do we go about doing this?
Well, we just – we first take the actual test
list and the interesting test itself and if test itself is
not interesting, then we return none. Because if
it’s not interesting, none of its subsets are going to
be interesting either. Otherwise we continue on
and we set a size and a current test, best size and
best test to be the length of the current test and
test itself. Because we know those are interesting
since we didn’t return and we want to hopefully
find a smaller subset, so that we can narrow down
where we are and where the bug we care about
actually is. So we run through all the subsets of
test and I will go through how we implemented
that in a second. And for every element smaller in
all the possible subsets of the test list, we check if
first of all the length of the subset is less than the
current best size – the current size of the – of an
interesting test list and that this element is also
interesting. If it is, then we reset the new best test
to be this smaller subset and the current best size
to be equal to the length of this smaller subset.
And we keep running through this until we find
hopefully the smaller subset or a smallest subset.
We might have two interesting subsets that are the
same size, that’s possible. And then once we’re all
done with checking through all possible subsets,
we just return the best test. Now to get all the
subsets, which is something called a power set, if
you’re familiar with set theory, we run it through
this other function called ‘all subsets’ that takes a
list, sets an element called ‘power set’ or ‘P set’
that is a list containing just the empty list, because
the empty list is always a subset of everything
because it’s nothing. And for every element in the
list, we add two P set for all X that are currently
in P set, that plus the element we’re talking about.
And this is really something that you should
probably play with and see how it acts, to really
buy that this does what it says it does. It’s a really
clever piece of code. And then we just return this.
And this is just all the possible subsets, including
the set itself. So what the all subsets method really
does is it takes a list, let’s say list 1, 2, 3, and it
returns all of the subsets of that list. So you would
have the empty list and you would also have the
subsets containing just one element and then all
the subsets containing two elements or sub lists –
I keep saying subsets; really these are lists and it’s
not strictly the same thing, but we can treat them
like that for now. And then all the subsets
containing three elements, which is actually just
the overarching list itself. And this is what the
function of all subsets returns. Now to test this,
we have a few test cases down here, and we
already had the interesting test that we talked
about earlier and we run test one through that and
test one is this fragment of code up here.
So variable X, variable Y, variable Z. X equals Y
plus Z. Y equals Z and Z equals X plus X. So we
run that through in – through auto debug and we
should find that this is the smallest interesting
fragment. And we see the first true statement,
means that this is true. To find another interesting
test, for this one, it’s just a list is interesting if it
contains three numbers in strict sending order.
And then we take some numbers here that we’ve
generated somewhat randomly and we check auto
debug against test two and interesting two.
And just by hand-checking this, you should see
that the length of the smallest interesting subset is
three, which we can see; when it ran it, we got
true, and indeed, if we check if the answer from
this is itself interesting – if we run it back
through interesting, we see that it is true.
So our function for auto debugging or at least
some auto debugging works fairly nicely.